first there's other news we wanted to
get to and that includes an update on
the bite administration's armed
Crackdown on its critics earlier this
month a longtime FBI agent and SWAT team
veteran called Steve friend came forward
to blow the whistle on what he has seen
happen to the FBI under Joe Biden and
what he said was shocking according to
agent friend Biden's FBI routinely uses
heavily armed SWAT teams to raid the
homes of American citizens who dare to
criticize the administration now to be
clear these are people who pose no
danger to anyone these people who
haven't even been accused much less
convicted of a violent crime so the
point is not to bring Justice the point
is to terrify and intimidate Joe Biden's
political opponents
hard to believe that's happening but it
is last year to name just one example
the FBI's counter terrorism division
raid the home of a 69 year old Red Cross
volunteer called Joseph Bolanos an
anonymous snitch had claimed that
Bolanos was at the Capitol on January 6.
not that he did anything
violent but that he was there it turns
out that wasn't even true it was a lie
but the feds moved forward and destroyed
bolanos's life anyway they showed up
with guns they stole his electronic
devices and then refused to return them
the whole experience was so traumatic
that Joseph blanos suffered two strokes
well on September 19th the FBI suspended
agent Steve friend for daring to reveal
what was happening these abuses now it's
illegal under federal law to punish
whistleblowers but the FBI did it anyway
and then four days later with friend out
of the way on the morning of September
23rd a team of nearly 30 FBI agents
bristling with automatic weapons raided
the home of yet another harmless man
with no criminal record that man's name
was Mark Houck Houck is 47 he's a leader
in his local Catholic Community FBI
agents pointed rifles at Houck and his
wife in front of their seven children
once again to be clear hauk is not a
terrorist he's never been accused of
terrorism he is instead a pro-lifer
Houck founded an organization called the
King's Men it's a pro-life group that
encourages men to be leaders in their
communities
now to give you a sense of who how kids
we want to play this for you here he is
describing the experience he had earlier
this year praying outside an abortion
clinic with his son
a woman came out who had an abortion and
we offered her some post-abortion
healing and um
well we just said we'll pray for you and
as we were praying
um the sorrowful mysteries I brought my
son over I said come on let's kneel down
we're gonna do this and we're gonna
leave she she got into it she she
started attacking us personally while we
were praying the sorrowful mysteries I
said son this is what the Lord's talking
about when he said they they hated me
they're gonna hate you they persecuted
me they're gonna push I whispered this
to him as she was spewing all this
vulgarity onto him and me and you know I
just sold this is what it's going to
take this is what we have to do this is
part of the journey
so that's Mark Houck now he's a
religious man not everyone is a
religious person not everyone agrees
with Mark houg but there's no doubt that
Mark Houk is a peaceful is a non-violent
person
in October of last year hap was standing
outside another abortion clinic in
Pennsylvania he was joined Again by his
12 year old son that's when a man
approached and began harassing the boy
so defend his son Houck pushed the
extremists back that was it local police
looked into it the District Attorney's
Office looked into it nobody pressed
charges against Mark how because it's
not assault to protect your son from an
extremist who's attacking him
but the Biden justice department decided
to revise this View and they charged
markout with a federal crime a felony
obstructing abortion access there was no
evidence that he had obstructed abortion
access but that's what he charged him
with
now howk learned about three months ago
that the doj planned to charge him and
he offered to turn himself in
voluntarily that's what a civilized
country allows but that wasn't good
enough for Merrick Garland's doj they
wanted to punish him and terrify his
family to send the right message to
anyone who would dare get in the way of
the Biden agenda so the doj sent a team
of federal agents with rifles to houck's
home he now faces 11 years in prison for
protecting his son
now again it's hard to believe that any
of that actually happened but it
actually did subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight